talking about how the water level out at
lake mead well as it continues to sink
and gas prices continue to rise how are
you supposed to have fun in the great
outdoors well our mary jane belgian live
in the far southeast valley out at lake
las vegas adapting to changing
circumstances kind of the name of the
game out there huh mary jane
oh absolutely nate and that seems to be
the direction for the summer you know i
spoke to one local business skiwi
rentals you know they've seen steady
business in the past but this year is
completely different with more families
looking to get outside with social
distancing scooby rentals in henderson
saw a good flow of customers but now
owner craig kelling says this time of
year is usually busy but inflation and
low water levels and lake mead is
impacting his business so as a way to
keep his doors open he's opened up
another shop called skiwee marines doing
repair services and upholstery work on
boats and jet skis and he's even renting
out paddle boards and kayaks as another
option for families looking to have some
fun but also want to save a few bucks
this summer
i mean you see this fleet here normally
this time of year at least two-thirds of
those would be out right now but right
now with the with the lake going down
people having problems getting into the
lake there's only two lanes open we're
suggesting that people go down to willow
beach and cottonwood cove on lake mojave
now kelling says he's not the only
business that's had to make changes and
anticipates water levels that lake need
to drop even more this summer so in the
meantime he hopes to cater to the
community and new customers any way he
can and he's also opening up a utv tour
business by the start of labor day
weekend and you know if you don't want
to travel that far out to lake mojave i
mean why not come down here to lake las
vegas and you can see even though
there's no open swimming allowed you can
still come out with your paddle board
and kayak they're also going to have
movies back on the water this summer so
plenty of fun family friendly things to
do reporting live at lake las vegas mary
june ballista live local now thank you